Compute twenty-five hundred
times 80, or 2,500 times 80.
Now, we could just do this
multiplication problem like a
traditional one, but when you
have these numbers with a lot
of zeroes there, and it actually
sometimes helps you
do it in your head, is
to kind of think
about the zeroes later.
And the reason why we can do
that-- let's rewrite this
multiplication problem.
2,500 times 80.
This is equivalent to--
2,500 is what?
It's 25 times 100.
This is equivalent
to 25 times 100.
That's what 2,500 is.
2,500 is 25 times
100 times 80.
And what's 80?
80 is 8 times 10.
And in multiplication, you can
rearrange it any way you like.
You can change the order when
it's all a bunch of numbers
being multiplied.
So this is the same thing, this
is the equivalent to 25
times 8 times 100 times 10.
And in the future, you're going
to be able to do this in
your head, but I really want
to show you why you can do
this in your head, why you can
just multiply 25 times 8, and
then worry about the zeroes.
So what's this going
to be equal to?
So this is going to be
equal to 25 times 8.
And what's 100 times 10?
Well, 100 times 10 is 1,000.
You can maybe do that
in your head.
And whenever you multiply powers
of ten, the way you can
think about it is you just
literally add the zeroes.
You had two zeroes here.
You have one zero here.
When you take their product,
you're going to get something
with three zeroes.
100 times 10 is 1,000.
And when we multiply this times
whatever this is, we'll
literally just add three zeroes
to the product, so
that's why this is useful.
We can now think about this as
being-- this is the same thing
as 25 times 8, and then whatever
25 times 8 is, we can
then add three zeroes to it.
Hopefully, this explained
a little bit about why.
Let's figure out what
25 times 8 is.
25 times 8.
5 times 8 is 40.
Put the zero down.
Carry the 4.
8 times 2 is 16 plus 4 is 20.
So it's an even 200,
which makes sense.
4 times 24 is 100, or four
quarters make a $1.00, so
eight quarters would
make $2.00, so
that all makes sense.
So this part right here is
200, so we're going to
multiply 200 times 1,000.
The easiest way to think about
it is you just add the zeroes
when you're multiplying
times a power of ten.
So this is going to be-- we're
going to have a 200, or you
could just imagine you have 2,
0, 0, and then you add the
three zeroes there.
One, two, three, and you
are left with 200,000.
So 2,500 times 80: 200,000.
You could've multiplied it out
in the traditional sense, but
it's good to see this-- I guess
you could call it a
trick or a way to do it in
your head a little bit.
And you'll see that more
and more, the more
practice you get.